c'est une surprise un peu particulière
ce matin pour un grand nombre
d'automobilistes dans cette
station-service le compteur n'indique
rien d'anormal mais quand on se rend à
la pompe impossible de se servir en
diesel une rupture qui agace cette
conductrice ce qui m'agace c'est qu'il y
en a qui ont peur de manquer mais qui
leur reste d'essence ils viennent faire
le plein alors que ils ont encore de
l'essence on attend depuis en avoir pour
faire son plan tout simplement et là on
va se retrouver dans la panade avec des
gens c'est les gens qui créent la
pénurie en fait comme d'autres usagers
cette retraité a dû faire quelques
stations services avant de trouver la
bonne Auchan
a été fermé était il y avait pas du tout
d'essence donc je reviens vers Leclerc
ici pour voir tout comme les raffineries
certains dépôts pétroliers sont aussi
fermés les deux sites de
Saint-Pierre-des-Corps eux ne sont pas
concernés une raison qui a conduit un
grand nombre de chauffeurs routiers ce
matin à s'alimenter sur le site je roule
en renfort et je suis surtout parce que
bon c'est bloqué voilà et c'est la
première fois non c'est pas la première
fois qu'on a besoin on file des coups de
main comme ça pour pour aider les gars
qui peuvent pas faire toutes les
tournées dans la journée quoi même si
l'ensemble des raffineries du territoire
est actuellement bloqué l'Union
française des industries pétrolières
affirment que les stocks sont hauts une
réserve anticipée en prévision des
mouvements sociaux reste à savoir pour
combien de temps